bentrovati potenza e fragilità e
qualcuno di voi si domanderà che cosa
hanno a che fare queste due parole
apparentemente così lontane dovete
sapere che fino a qualche tempo fa le
mie due figlie più grandi marte
francesca e per addormentarsi
sceglievano due parole e io su quelle
due parole dovevo raccontare una storia
ora questa cosa non me la chiedono più
perché loro sono diventate grandi ma io
no e quindi la storia lo vorrei
raccontare a voi questa sera allora la
storia inizia con il solito bambino
ricciolino vivace ma intrappolato da un
terribile incantesimo le parole facevano
fatica ad uscire proprio rimanevano
bloccate nella sua bocca comunque
passano gli anni il bambino diventa un
ragazzo però ci soffre molto moltissimo
su questo problema delle balbuzie tant'è
che prova a incontrare e psicologi
logopedisti tutti bravissime persone
bravissimi professionisti ma nessuno
riesce a sciogliere questo incantesimo
un giorno fa un viaggio a roma
e così per pura fortuna incontra una
vecchietta si chiamava teresa di
calcutta e questa vecchietta dice al
ragazzo quando un giorno aspetterai un
figlio qualsiasi cosa succeda non avere
paura
tant'è che tutti intorno distro madre
teresa ma che belle parole di libertà è
invece il ragazzo penso io non sono
interessato a queste parole di libertà
io voglio libertà per le mie parole
comunque passarono ancora negli anni è
il sogno di questo ragazzo era di
diventare un attore comico
e invece diventa un ingegnere
informatico perché era molto più
semplice digitare le parole davanti a un
computer che recitare parole davanti a
un pubblico ma un bel giorno e nella
piazza del suo paese stavano allestendo
una grande festa con un palcoscenico e
un microfono proprio lì nel mezzo
ora voi potete immaginare cosa significa
un microfono per un attore comico ma
immaginate anche cosa significa un
microfono per un balbuziente ma il
desiderio di questo ragazzo di provare
le battute che aveva scritto le battute
comiche era troppo grande e non ci penso
salì i gradini del palcoscenico prete
prese il microfono e disse e salve a
tutti sono un ingegnere informatico
pensate che sono così bravo in internet
che le mie prime parole appena nato sono
state web web successe proprio così le
persone ridevano e lui era felice perché
le parole uscivano fluide nell'aria era
successa una magia era successo qualche
cosa di eccezionale ma la cosa più bella
che questo ragazzo apprezzava in quel
momento era che le persone non ridevano
più di lui ma ridevano con lui
ecco a questo punto una delle mie figlie
mi avrebbe interrotto e avrebbe detto sì
papa abbiamo capito che sei te e poi
comunque ti sei dimenticato hai parlato
della fragilità amati si è dimenticato
di dire della potenza allora io dressy
ragazzi questo è un po il problema di
avere il papa egocentrico direbbe la
mamma ma la potenza ci arrivò prima però
devo dirvi una cosa importantissima
perché quando io parlavo delle mie
disabilità delle mie debolezze succedeva
una cosa stranissima le persone che
avevo davanti sembravano più disponibili
più gentili
insomma tiravano fuori il meglio di loro
stessi cosa cosa un attimo
io parlo delle mie disabilità
loro tirano fuori la parte migliore e se
funzionasse anche al contrario
e allora che sono diventato volontario
in una casa che ospita persone con
disabilità o funzionava funzionava le
persone tutte le persone che ho
incontrato e che sono diventate parte
della mia vita
hanno tirato fuori che stanno tirando
fuori veramente la parte migliore di me
e questa cosa è meravigliosa però come
in tutte le storie che si rispettino c'è
sempre un momento difficile un momento
buio perché credetemi incontrare una
disabilità può fare un po paura ma per
chi è genitore o sta diventando genitore
generare disabilità ed è quella è la più
grande delle paure e allora la scena
cambia e andiamo all'ospedale civile di
padova siamo convocati io e mia moglie
che è incinta una dottoressa ci fa
accomodare in una stanza in a
piccolissima con una meravigliosa e luce
al neon dove serve una sola sedia e fa
accomodare mia moglie prende il foglio e
legge trisomia 21
a quel punto per me il tempo si ferma è
l'unica ecco che o nelle mie orecchie
sono le parole di quella vecchietta di
calcutta zombie afraid non avere paura
ma il colpo di genio c'è la mia moglie
che dice e si scusi dottoressa ma nostro
figlio è un maschio e una femmina
la dottoressa dice scusi signora forse
lei non ha ben capito e trisomia 21
è la sindrome di down mia moglie
risponde e non dottoressa ho capito
benissimo ma volevo solo sapere se il
nostro figlio è un maschio o una femmina
allora la dottoressa sempre più spaesata
cerca è femmina
allora io ho quel punto dico è una porca
miseria non siamo neanche stavolta
riusciti a fare il maschio daniela ma
insomma la dottoressa abbiamo dato a 6
alla dottoressa per
perché grazie
e noi
grazie
noi ci scherziamo molto su questa cosa
ma vi assicuro che è stato ovviamente un
momento molto difficile forse il più
difficile della della nostra vita
anche perché non so se l'avete capito ma
non siamo dei supereroi
comunque dopo pochi mesi è arrivata anna
è quella ve la presento che è una
meraviglia è è bellissima è anche forte
ammetto che il mio è un giudizio un po
di parte l'avete capito e comunque la
cosa più bella che anna ha portato nelle
nostre famiglie la cosa veramente
meravigliosa è che ci ha reso tutti
persone migliori migliore ma è migliore
mia moglie migliore le sue sorelle e
tutte le persone che in qualche modo
incontriamo e se non è potenza questa
però abbiamo notato una cosa che tutte
le persone che incontriamo sono tutte
molto informate dal punto di vista
tecnico della disabilità in particolare
della sindrome di down siamo tutti
cintura nera di villocentesi di analisi
sappiamo tutto ma poche molto poche di
queste persone hanno avuto degli
incontri con persone con disabilità e
allora per mettere insieme un po perché
queste cose e raccontare la nostra
storia abbiamo deciso di aprire una
pagina facebook che si chiama buone
notizie secondo anna dove così senza
prenderci troppo sul serio ma proprio
per niente anzi direi raccontiamo le
buone notizie che ci porta anna per per
esempio un po di tempo fa
francesca è venuta a casa e dicendo non
sapete che usano down come un'offesa a
scuola
e allora abbiamo fatto questa cartolina
dove anna dice ma è vero che a volte
usata e massei down come fosse un'offesa
bella questa e voi sareste up quindi che
sta provando oppure un'altra ancora dove
dice ma è vero che dite affetto da
sindrome di down e non dite affetto da
occhi azzurri bella pensa si dice con
sindrome di down
perché crediamo che anche le parole
abbiano la loro importanza anche perché
se parliamo di sindrome di down
voi lo sapete è semplicemente un
cromosoma in più una ics in più non so
vi faccio un esempio avete presente il
ted aggiungete una piccola hicks no
perché vi faccio questo esempio perché
voi perché voi oggi per conoscere il ted
parlare col ted parlare con le persone
avete fatto un po di fatica ecco quindi
l'invito è fate un po di fatica e non
evitate gli incontri di disabilità che
avrete nella vostra vita e sia sia
personali ma anche delle persone che vi
stanno intorno
una piccolissima raccomandazione però in
questo percorso ci si può perdere perché
la tendenza nostra è sempre quella di
metterci un gradino sopra o un gradino
sotto
ecco per guardarsi negli occhi bisogna
mettersi allo stesso livello e in questo
senso a me capita spesso di perdermi per
questo mi piace come un moderno
pollicino lasciare dei sassolini lungo
le mie storie
ebbene l'ho fatto anche questa sera con
questo segno che nel linguaggio dei
segni è la parola disabilità quindi non
vi resta che augurarvi di cercare tracce
di disabilità nella vostra vita di
accoglierle e soprattutto ricordate che
le paure che riuscite a guardare in
faccia si trasformano in coraggio grazie
di cuore davvero